Courtney?
Court...
You guys sure about this
yeah whatever
you put these kids in real danger
Wait! We need to stick together!
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Green Lantern trailer
video they just teased another new Green
Lantern being minted by Alan Scott's old
Green Lantern battery so we'll break it
down there's a bunch of Easter eggs that
get into what's going on with Green
Lantern in the larger DC Universe the
stuff that they're doing in the
arrowverse with the Green Lantern
characters the stuff that's happening
with the HBO Green Lantern and then the
Justice League Snider cut version of the
Hal Jordan Green Lantern so I'll explain
everything that's going on because
believe it or not there is still a big
Green Lantern Corps movie that DC is
planning on making I've also got a lot
of questions about what's going on with
the mysterious janitor who everyone
thinks is dr. fate I think it's a good
guess so I'll talk about him at the end
of the video too careful
if you're not familiar with Alan Scott's
back story in the comics he became a
Green Lantern in a very different way
from say like Hal Jordan Jon Stewart the
other modern-day Green Lantern Corps
members the reason why the Green Lantern
battery is glowing is because the starheart has recognized its next user that
means that the show is just teasing that
we're going to find out who this next Green
Lantern is going to be I have a lot of
theories about that because of the way
that they're selecting the new members
of the modern-day Justice Society but
the whole idea here is that this battery
is actually made from the starheart an
experimental weapon developed by the
Owens that then came to Planet Earth as
a meteorite was found in ancient China
someone fashioned a lantern battery
around it than the original green
lantern that you saw during episode one
they teased him here but we haven't
actually seen him walk past the camera
yet Alan Scott found this Lantern
battery in because the starheart is
this sentience
it told him how to fashion his own Green
Lantern ring from the battery and then
that's how he became a Green Lantern so
whereas modern-day Green Lantern's have
to go back to OA to the main power
battery to recharge their rings Alan
Scott uses this Lantern battery to
recharge himself cool Easter Egg from
the Justice League Snyder cut - this is
actually kind of tying things to the
movies so if you remember the Green
Lantern from the big Darkseid war
flashback that's yeah Langer he was the
Green Lantern of Earth's sector about
2,000 years ago when he died his body
was so powerful that he was taken back
to OA and his body became part of the
starheart so his body is part of what
powers this Lantern battery here on the
TV show Geoff Johns did tease that they
are going to do a version of green lantern
on the show just like they're doing new
versions of all these characters like
the new hour man the new star girl all
the other new characters but here's the
thing in a lot of cases the new members
of the Justice Society they're taking up
the mantle of these old heroes or
sometimes their children sometimes
they're not their children but in the
case of Alan Scott Green Lantern he does
have biological children that are part
of previous TV Justice Society stories
one of them is obsidian he was a boy
the other one was Jade a girl obsidian
was featured on legends of tomorrow
during season two he was actually played
by Lance Henriksen so it was a much
older version of the character most of
the bigger Jade comic book stories were
during the Kyle Rayner Green Lantern era
when he became the main version of Green
Lantern
but the whole concept with this Justice
Society TV show is that a lot of the
Justice Society members had secret
families with children who they didn't
tell their secrets to so you have a lot
of kids growing up not knowing that
their parents were famous superheroes
most of these Justice Society artifacts
they stole from the Hall of Justice are
either alive or they have magical
properties so they can sense when their
next user is nearby like our man's
hourglass starts glowing when it comes
near his son so that's why the Green
Lantern battery is glowing it senses
that the next Green Lantern is somewhere
nearby and it's probably early
prediction going to be Jade we haven't
seen her on the TV show as far as we
know she could just be a background
character the way Geoff Johns talks
about it it sounds like he has bigger
green lantern plans on the TV show for
next season but they haven't been
renewed for season two yet all they've
really said about the HBO Green Lantern
series is that it's not going to be
connected to a lot of the air over stuff
it'll be more connected to what's going
on in the future DC movies it'll be
super big-budget they'll be doing a
version of Hal Jordan Jon Stewart in
Sinestro and it'll cover a couple of
different time periods early prediction
that's just because they want to do how
Jordan's backstory they want to do
sinestro's backstory which obviously
takes place way further in the past from
how Jordan's backstory but they also
want to do Jon Stewart's origin story
which takes place a long time after Hal
Jordans origin story they didn't say how
many episodes is going to be but because
they're spending so much money on it I'm
assuming it'll only be six to eight
episodes per season but it does sound
like it will run for multiple seasons
it's not going to be just a single
miniseries they haven't said much about
what's going on with the Green Lantern
Corps movie right now but they're still
making it it sounds like most of their
attention though has shifted to this HBO
Green Lantern series temporarily the
Justice League Snyder cut does have a
version of how Jordan in it he was being
played by this actor Sam Benjamin we
don't know exactly what was happening
with his character he wasn't a huge part
of the movie but it sounds like we'll
see him again
during the Justice League Snyder cut
next year hopefully they'll find a way
to work him into the trailer then you
have all the arrowverse Green Lantern
stuff that they teased in the arrow
finale and crisis on Infinite Earths
Diggle got a Green Lantern ring he
actually showed the behind the scenes
for this it was just a glowing green
light in a box DC said that they had
very specific rules that would allow
them to use this green
interns seen in this finale scene Diggle
is busy moving his family to Metropolis
where Superman lives they're doing the
Superman TV show next year so even if
Diggle isn't going to be a main character
on the new Superman TV show it sounds
like they'll handle all the follow-up
Diggle Green Lanterns stuff on the
Superman TV show which makes sense I
mean it's one of the biggest ticket
items that you have in the DC Universe
we haven't done a lot of Green Lantern
stuff in there so far why wouldn't you
do it on your biggest new show in this
trailer footage you also probably notice
as they're trying to form their new
version of the Justice Society they're
fighting Sportsmaster his wife tigress
but you don't see Artemis anywhere there
is a version of Artemis that's a member
of this high school the play give her an
origin story sometime later this season
or in season two most of you know those
characters from Young Justice
because Artemis was such a big character
during that series especially during
Young Justice season three just sitting
there waiting for Wally West to appear
out of the speedforce
I know those of you that are big Young
Justice fans they are making Young
Justice season 4 though pry be an
announcement about that at the big DC
fandom Comic Con later this summer as
for the big doctor fate seen that
everyone's asking about everyone saw the
scene of the janitor he tells the new
doctor midnite beware there are dragons
in the water which sounds like a very
dr. fate thing to say but he's just this
senile looking old janitor that sounds
like he's talking crazy obviously we
know that's not true this is a comic
book show he's speaking in riddles for a
reason when he says there are dragons in
the water is a reference to the in
Justice Society who are running a
brainwashing program in Blue Valley
called Project new America is their very
insidious plan to slowly take over
America if you remember the way they
used dr. fate on the Smallville TV show
way back in the day you saw that when he
wasn't wearing the helmet he was
actually kind of senile and he didn't
really become doctor fate get his wits
about him until he put the helmet back
on infused with the spirit of Naboo he's
never won don't whisper too loudly
don't show me what could be or not be
felis everything
so my guess is is that this old man is
just a plant from the Justice Society
here to keep an eye on the injustice
society most of them who are hiding in
plain sight is members of the faculty in
the school the helmet of fate is still
back at the Hall of Justice so I'm
guessing we probably won't see a ton of
doctor faith stuff either till towards
the end of the season or maybe not till
season two but they'll probably pay off
that Easter Egg sometime before the end
of the season but everyone let me know
in the comments what do you want them to
do with a new version of green lantern
that they just teased they're
introducing on the show and what do you
want them to do with the doctor fake
character there are also rumors that
they're going to do it just a society movie
based on the version of the team that
they're doing inside the blackout a
movie but we'll see how that winds up
going we haven't even seen the Black
Adam movie yet everyone click here for
my new Justice League Snyder cut trailer
video in Easter eggs and click here for
my new Star Wars mandalorian video about
the dark saber and Mark Hamill's secret
cameo scene thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe I'll see
you guys tonight!